This person at hospital treatment recently, blood transfusion and hemoglobin had bowed
stuff with the transfusion, had a CT scan, the tumor had grown and it was pressing on the
jugular. That's what they were thinking that it was pressing on the aorta in the jugular.
That's why it wasn't operable and it looks like it's pressing on the jugular and it's blocking
the flow on the right side of the neck. They feel as the tumor grows and will continue to bleed
and eventually press too hard on the crotted artery or the jugular and it could or stilcologist
says it could be days, weeks or whatever for this to happen. He was, the patient was putting
the right on his stomach or chest. Can't he run the tumor all, run on the tumor all night?
Yes, you can put it up close to the cancer, close to the tumor as possible, the better,
that's my belief. And he should be running the programs that we made for him.
Will this cause diock to be too fast? No, I don't think so, I don't know.
So please keep this person in your prayers. I just hope that all of you are prayed for each
other. We dig.